In the last lesson we learned exactly how an individual
gene gets turned into a protein. This genetic code we
analogize to a book of recipes representing our genome.We want
to revisit this analogy for this lesson but we going to
think about it a little bit different. Instead of these
ingredents being used to make a single protein. We're going to take
each of these ingredients individually as a its own protein
to build a particular trait or even a whole human being.
Let's get started. And, if we want to build
a human being the first thing I'm going to do
is take our ingredient which represents one protein.
And then then I'll start measuring out one tablespoon.
>> Okay. Okay so this is one protein? That's right.
>> Well, one human coming right up.
>> Lauren, did you just pour all of the flour in the bowl?
>> Yeah, you said flour was in the recipe, and I'm assuming
it takes a lot of flower to make a human. We're huge.
>> This is
true, but it's like a gene. You can't add the whole thing at once. You've
got to add the right amount at the right time to get the right produce.
>> Well, I'm sorry, but I guess you're
right. There are over 20,000 genes in the
human genome. If we added all of them all at once all at the same time,
every cell would be identical. Because they'd all
have the same ingredients at the same time,
and obviously that's not what we want. To
get different cell types at different times, we actually
need to add different ingredients at different times in different amounts. So
we must specify these ingredients, and we have to specify the amounts.
>> Well where does the specificity come from.
Like how does a skin cell know to
be a skin cell, and how does a brain cell know to be a brain cell?
>> The short answer is development. Development is a process
by which the right gene is added at the right time
to make the right cell type. It's how cell knows
to be a certain cell type out of the many thousands
it could possibly be, for example, the cells in your hand.